ok vamos a hacer este ejercicio que dice
escribiendo fracciones con decimales que
se repiten y bueno nos dicen que
expresemos el número racional 45 entre
54 y tú puedes ver que es un número
racional porque tenemos una fracción con
un decimal
finito o en su dado caso como un decimal
que eventualmente se repite y es que es
la clave para diferenciar de un número
racional a un número irracional es que
justamente un número racional o es un
número decimal finito o es un número con
decimal que eventualmente se repite
mientras que cuando nosotros tenemos un
número irracional tenemos un número
decimal pero que nunca se repite y de
aquí lo importante es que un número
racional tarde o temprano se repite pero
bueno en este caso tenemos 45 entre 54
ya esto lo tenemos que convertir en un
número decimal así que vamos a hacerlo
manos a la obra
voy a poner aquí mi pizarrón para poner
el 45 entre 54 aquí tengo 45 45 entre 54
y bueno si te das cuenta
esta es una fracción que realmente lo
que te está diciendo es que al 45 lo
tenemos que dividir entre 54 al 45 lo
tenemos que dividir entre el 54 y nos
podemos tomar esta división así que
vamos a hacerla a esto es lo mismo que
poner el 45 adentro de la casita voy a
poner un punto de varios ceros porque
nos vamos a tomar su parte decimal y
además 54 no cabe ninguna vez completa
en 45 y aquí voy a poner la casa de la
división y aquí afuera el 54 y como nos
tomamos una división pues bueno vamos a
hacerla con calma esto es exactamente lo
mismo que ponemos aquí el punto decimal
no cabe ninguna vez y entonces tengo 450
54 es cercano a 50 por lo tanto el 450
cuenta cabe nueve veces pero como 54 es
un poco más grande entonces le voy a
poner otro 8 por 4 32 y llevamos 3 lo
voy a tener aquí a 8 por 5 es 43 43 y
perfecto si grupo exacto así que me voy
a tomar la diferencia de estos dos y
dice 2 para 10 es 8 bajan y me queda 45
menos 44 en lo cuales 1 y ahora sí voy a
bajar este otro 0 para seguir con la
división 54
cuántas veces cabe en el 180 y voy a
quitar este 3 para no confundirnos
bueno pues 54 es parecido a 50 así que
50 cabe tres veces en 150 y en 180
también va a caber tres veces por lo
tanto voy a poner aquí un 33 por 4 es 12
y llevamos una 3 por 5 es 15 y la una
que llevábamos que voy a poner aquí son
16 16 yo sí me voy a tomar la diferencia
de estos dos y me queda dos para 10 es
y llevo una la voy a sumar acá abajo
1817 es 1 y ya te diste cuenta aquí
empieza a verse el patrón aquí me quedo
de residuo 18 aquí me quedé donde
residió 18 y otra vez voy a bajar este 0
de aquí me va a quedar otra vez de nuevo
180 y hasta tú me puedes decir de una
manera muy rápida que aquí va otro 33
por 54 es 162 que es justo este número
que tenemos aquí y si nosotros nos
tomamos la diferencia vamos a obtener de
residuos 18 y así podemos seguir
poniendo ceros y poniendo 3 aquí y
seguir tomándonos esta división hasta
cansarnos ahora lo que quiero que te des
cuenta es que ya sabemos que 45 entre 54
45 entre 54 es lo mismo que 0.83 y bueno
tú sabes que después de este 3 se va a
repetir otro 3 otro 3 otro 3 otro 3 y es
justo lo que te decía hace rato cuando
nosotros tomamos un número racional es
decir una fracción siempre
vamos a encontrar que este número
racional tiene una parte decimal
periódica como en este caso y también
por cierto cuando tenemos una parte
decimal periódica es decir que se repite
lo que se repite aquí es el 333 333 y
esto sigue y sigue y sigue
no podemos escribir de la siguiente
manera 45 entre 54 es exactamente lo
mismo que 0.83 y lo que se repite
solamente es el número 3 por lo tanto
voy a poner una línea arriba del 3 que
significa que es periódico periódico
significa que lo que se va a repetir es
esta parte de aquí se va a repetir 33
333 33 hasta el infinito y esta es como
una forma compacta de ver al 45 entre 54
sin tomarnos toda la cola de 3 es ahora
también lo que quiero que veas es que el
45 entre 54 de una vez lo podríamos
simplificar esto es lo mismo que si saco
tercera arriba me queda 15 15 por 3 lo
estoy dividiendo entre 3 la parte de
arriba 3 por 15 45 y si saco tercera
abajo
si a esto lo divido entre 3 me va a
quedar 3 cabe una vez en 5 me quedan 2 3
por 8 y 24 15 entre 18 por ciento eso
también se puede simplificar esto es
exactamente lo mismo que sacó la tercera
arriba me queda 5 favorecerse abajo y me
queda 65 sextos y si te das cuenta si yo
me toma ahora 5 sextos y dividido 5
entre 6 voy a obtener lo mismo y aquí
pongo un cero un punto decimal bajó un 0
y digo 6 cuántas veces claves 50 6 por 8
48 por lo tanto aquí voy a poner un 8
voy a poner esto largo largo largo largo
8 por 6 48 entonces le voy a quitar 48 y
entonces me residuo es 2 bajo este 0 que
tengo aquí va a coste cero que tengo
aquí ojo recuerda que existe el punto
decimal y me va a quedar 20 entre 6 lo
cual es 33 por 6 18 y me sobran 2
entonces bajo otro 0 con otro 33 mil 618
me sobran dos bajo otro 0 con otro 3 y
así no puedo seguir y seguir seguir y
seguir lo que quiero que veas es que si
nosotros nos tomamos
original o si nosotros nos tomamos a la
fracción identificada llegamos a la
misma parte de semana y eso es muy
importante muchas veces es mucho más
fácil tomarnos a la fracción
simplificada que la fracción original
bueno pues ya sabemos que el resultado
es 0.8 333 33 así que vamos a ponerlo y
por cierto aquí nos dicen en el problema
regresamos al problema expresa el número
racional 45 entre 54 como un número
decimal finito o como un número decimal
que eventualmente se repite que es el
caso y nos dice después que incluyamos
solo los primeros 4 dígitos del estimar
en tu respuesta así que ya tenemos los
primeros 4 dígitos es 0.8 y después
seguía un 3 y después seguía un 3 y
después siguieron 3 y así nos podemos
mantener poniendo 13 ahora ten cuidado
nos dicen que incluyamos solamente los 8
primeros dígitos del estimar en nuestra
respuesta
así que si ponemos otro 3 la respuesta
estaría mal porque estaríamos metiendo
un quinto dígito
redondeamos a 8.330 porque este trecho
podríamos bajar también al redondear
estaremos poniendo una respuesta
incorrecta lo que nos piden es que
pongamos tal cual los cuatro primeros
dígitos del decimal en esta parte en mi
respuesta así que comprobemos respuesta
y perfecto ya está nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo